brandon another day another win with the
black pieces in the djoko piano another
incredible idea in the opening do you
consider yourself already an expert in
the joko piano do you want to play black
every single game
well i think i just got lucky that my
opponents played lines specific movers
that allowed these ideas
the main way of playing with rookie one
in h3 doesn't really allow any
interesting ideas and you kind of just
have to go rookie bishop e6 and play
something normal
but i was definitely happy to see knight
d2 over the board because this net h5 i
mean i don't even know it too well
myself but i looked at it for a few
minutes and it's pretty unexplored it's
only been played a couple times at the
gm level um and it was uh three games
and none very conclusive for sure and i
i like i couldn't find a clear event
past an advantage for white and at least
i'm going to get an interesting game and
not something that my opponent has
analyzed so yeah already d4 i think is
probably inaccurate
um because the point is in all these
lines where i'm not castled he always
has to watch out for something like g5
and knight f4 queen f6 comes with like
an extra tempo before it before i castle
um so here knight b3 i believe is the
best move knight b3 knight b3 yeah
so it looks a bit in the wrong direction
right just to make room for the bishop
but like if knight f4 for example then
bishop b3 i'm not really creating any
threats and if you go queen f6 instead
of
if queen f6 and bishop g5 followed by
bishop e3 i think is totally playable
but it's actually kind of funny after
knight b3 i was planning on yeah i think
queen f6 was played in the game before
um
but i think after knight b3 castle is
supposed to be better
and it's pretty funny so bishop g5
knight f6 is the best move and okay
there they're a bunch of moves here for
white but one of the best moves is
knight bd2 background
so you're getting like a normal kind of
line except i forced him to play this
bishop g5 me and then you can play like
h65 and you can that's an interesting
game but it's kind of a funny way of
getting back to a normal position i hate
the joko piano yeah
my hatred has been confirmed as well
because g3 which felt wrong to me and i
have a lot of options here i mean i
probably spent too much time looking at
all this like h5 instead of h6 um queen
f6 at the right moment there are a lot
of different options for black but i
figured hx knight g5 was like the most
principle then
um
and here you spent a lot of time on this
move queen f6
yeah for sure so what was the reason for
that so okay i want to take on d4 of
course and then he has this knight f5
which is the which is what i actually
missed from a few moves before
um and it actually gets very dangerous
for me um
i think perhaps i can play something
like g6 here and i was trying to
evaluate this then he goes knight takes
d4
i can go knight back to h3
um but in all these lines like there are
a lot of these positions where i can win
the d-pawn and let's say he goes f4 here
where like my knight isn't i'm not
losing my knight but it's just kind of
stranded on h3 and i can win the d-pawn
but i wasn't really sure how to evaluate
these positions
so it's basically a much worse version
than what you got into right yeah
but after cleaning up six i didn't i
think knight f5 was not a good move um
i thought he should do something like
queen f3 instead of knight f5
um
and it's kind of interesting because
like
i don't know what white's next move is
but i don't know what black's move is
either like if you go bishop h3 and cast
along you can already start going b4 for
example
um
and another interesting line is bishop
let's say rookie one here bishop street
rookie one
um i probably wasn't gonna go bishop h3
because knight she's six now
and then i think knight f5 was pretty
scary
um
do you have any crazy ideas like g5
instead of knight g6 back probably not
yeah so i was gonna probably go knight
g6 immediately just my bishop doesn't
get stranded on h3
um and then
he can take the queen but then
it feels like black shouldn't really
have any problems here because i mean
the d-pawn is still hanging
so i thought maybe something like this
should happen and it's probably around
equal
and you were surprised by the fact that
he gave you the pawn with knight to five
f4 for sure how did you assess the
position right yeah so i thought this
was just really good for me but i think
instead of queen takes d4 i didn't need
to let any of this queen h5 i mean
bishop h3 here was was my first instinct
um but i missed this detail that after
e5
um
yeah so i saw that take uh do you take
c5 f takes e5 queen c6
all right okay f takes because
yeah if you d takes and queen c6 is just
probably winning for black queen c6 uh
d5
queen c5 let's say rookie one
yeah and it's like i wanted to cast
along here and then i thought okay queen
h5 and then it's unclear and i ended my
line here but i miss bishop g2 which i
realize as soon as i move that in the
end of all this i have bishop g2
that's nice yeah
if he doesn't go queen h5 then i think
his position just sort of falls apart
because where it takes d5 is a threat
and then
this should just be winning so bishop h3
kind of just avoids all this queen h5
stuff everywhere and then i'm probably
getting a better version of the game
um
but okay i think what i did was good
enough
but it got really interesting around
here so
that's a mistake really what is what is
the move then instead i think it was
surprising i think bishop d7 was what
was that that night has always
recommended f3 here bishop d7 um
what's the problem
i think queen f6 is good enough to
maintain a slight advantage okay it's
not that bad yeah i guess i was afraid i
don't know what i was afraid of there
but okay queen f6 knight f3 yeah i think
seven was very important actually right
yeah because otherwise it's it's f5 is
coming but okay instead of f5 there's
this interesting move bishop d2 which i
think he should have played
and here i was trying to calculate all
these lines um bishop d2 instead of f5
sorry
apologies
yeah and then i go queen g6
and okay objectively i white should
probably take on g6 and go bishop c3 and
you do have some compensation for that
pony has some activity maybe e5 is going
but black should be the only one who can
win that but after queen g6 there's this
move queen a5
what yeah
queen and
it looks super scary for black but i i
think i calculated my writing of this i
thought queen takes e4
queen c3
and okay g7 is hanging rookie one is
coming looks like black's like in big
trouble here but i think i have this
idea d5
bishop d3
and d4
d
and i'm just in time with my play and i
bring the queen back i have bishop b6
blocking d file if i need it i think
black is kind of surviving here
um
so
i'm pretty sure this was correct
but so i guess he should he should go
bishop b2 and then queen takes g6 and
try to draw that end game somehow but i
think after what i got in the game with
the queen trade and then once that was
pretty much smooth so yeah
brandon two uh big victories for you
congratulations tomorrow i think you
have a big game against the wonder uh
are you going to uh andrew andrew hong
yeah okay how are you going to get ready
for that one
um we're actually good friends we know a
lot of each other's openings so it's
going to be tough like to find something
that we haven't talked about before but
well yeah i'll see what i can come up
with tonight well looking forward to see
your game tomorrow thank you
thank you brandon congratulations